salve a tutti i ragazzi e prevenuti ma
questo nuovo video la camera è storta e
siamo sul mio canale ragazzi c'è una
roba che volevo fare da un po nel senso
che ne state parlando un più o meno
tutti ok di questa cosa si tratta del
teste delle personalità che cos'è il
test e personalità sostanzialmente
esistono 16 tipi di personalità quando
questo sito poi non so se praticamente
una roba un po più architettata che
queste sfumature di personalità ognuno
ha la propria e molti di voi negli
ultimi mesi forse addirittura
nell'ultimo anno mi hanno chiesto qual è
il mio tipo di personalità non lo so
cioè non è che non solo anche
personalità ma non so quella che mi
viene a seguire rassegnata quindi
facciamo il testo allo ragazzi tipi di
personalità abbiamo tutte queste sono i
vari tipi per iniziare test della
personalità paiono meno gli unici minuti
risponde lestamente anche se non ti
piace la risposta e cerca di non
lasciare imposta neutrali let's go provi
difficile presentarti ad altre persone
allora assolutamente sì penso che questo
sia la la potenza della risposta è al
massimo totalmente sono molto timido
questa cosa questo lo sapete tutti
quando sam personaggio pubblico quindi è
anche facile per te presentati nel senso
che hai tante cose da dire comunque il
tuo carattere
in qualche modo ti chiude non te lo fa
fare ci sono persone invece che magari
non fanno non fanno moltissimo durante
la giornata ma che comunque hanno un
sacco di cose da dire
questo vi fa capire quanto il carattere
influisca non è che non dipende dalle
cose che fai ma dipende dal quota come
sei e ci ritrovo molto spesso quindi
assolutamente sì spesso dei così
sovrappensiero da ignorare o dimenticare
la mente circostante guarda se ci fosse
un altro pallino lo farei però posso
schiacciare solo questo cerchi di
rispondere alle mail il prima possibile
non sopporti che la casa che la cartella
di posta in arrivo sia disordinata
questo sì però non così tanto
chi è facile mantenere la calma e la
concentrazione anche sotto pressione
falchi nono di solito non inizi le
conversazioni proprio
raramente fai qualcosa solo per pura
curiosità
questo invece falso nel senso che per
curiosità io faccio tante cose quindi
non andrei proprio sul gigantesco ma sul
sul medio ailes colti senti superiore
alle altre persone facciamo questo
allora io sono una persona che analizza
nel senso che quando guardo gli altri
oppure quando sono ad un evento in
particolare io analizzo l'evento trovo
pregi e difetti di tutto quello che
succede non solo delle persone ma anche
di di ciò che mi circonda e questo mi fa
sentire che poi non è così
per questo si parla di come ti senti tu
ma non è assolutamente così mi fa
sentire magari più lungimirante rispetto
ad altre persone che vi stanno perché mi
stanno vicino in quel momento che magari
non hanno analizzato tutto quello che
c'è intorno come l'ho fatto io questo è
quello che io penso ovviamente per te
essere organizzati e più importante
nell'essere flessibili ma di solito è un
elevata motivazione e molta energia
perché vincere un dibattito ma
importante del fare in modo che nessuno
si arrabbi falso in genere quando c'è un
dibattito è molto raro che io lo porti
avanti fino allo sfinimento perché tanto
proprio la motivazione che vi ho
spiegato qua del superiore tra
virgolette tendo a capire che quando una
persona non vuole capire la lascio nel
suo brodo c'è un po come i tempi quando
c'erano gli haters al the present art
dice fare youtuber non è un lavoro
cercatene 1 cioè non perdo i miei
secondi a spiegargli che un
rincoglionito ti senti spesso come se
dovessi giustificarti con gli altri
assolutamente sì e non so per quale
motivo non ti dispiace essere al centro
dell'attenzione ed i consiglieri una
persona più pratica che creativa è anzi
è doppio questo raramente le persone ti
fanno arrabbiare no
sì veramente cosa in sé non sono uno che
si arrabbia easy i tuoi piani di viaggio
di solito sono ben pensati eccolo qua
questo assolutamente sì in una
discussione la verità dovrebbe essere
più importante della suscettibilità
delle persone dipende ti preoccupi
raramente di come le frazioni abbiano un
effetto sugli altri
il falso mi preoccupo sempre come le
mense nel teatro sugli altri purtroppo
il tuo stile lavorativo si avvicina
maggiormente a picchi di energia casuali
che ha un approccio metodico e
organizzato o no fa falso falsino sei
spesso invidioso degli altri bloom mai
praticamente mai uguale ammetto qua
perché ovviamente è che capita però tipo
una volta ogni mille anni vinto con un
falsone ma guarda un libro un videogioco
interessante spesso meglio di un evento
sociale
sfatiamo questo mito dipendere
all'evento sociale nel senso non è
sempre così andiamo un po più passerini
ragazzi raramente ti lasci trasportare
da fantasie e idee
direi proprio falso perché i per falso
perché il mio lavoro è fatto di questo
quindi noti per gli spezzoni dei
pensieri quando cammina e la natura io
non cammino nella natura ma se lo
facessi sarebbe così quindi absolute se
qualcuno non risponde alla tua mail in
modo rapido inizia preoccuparvi aver
detto qualcosa di sbagliato è come
genitore è personalmente non lo fui
preferisci che tuo figlio cresca gentile
piuttosto che intelligente e non lo
mettiamo proprio la totale ma più o meno
bisogna anche saper essere gentili con
se stessi e molto spesso e io questa è
una cosa che facevo molto mettevo il
bene dell'altro prima del mio e questa
cosa sbagliata perché bisogna sempre a
mare più se stessi almeno quindi gentile
e io io sono una persona totalmente
rispettosa gentile nei confronti degli
altri non ho mai mancato di rispetto
però è anche vero che non bisogna cari
rispetto a se stessi non lasci che altre
persone influenti dalle creazioni
assolutamente sì io non metto sempre
perché comunque molto bisogno di aiuto e
quindi chiedo aiuto ai miei amici
però ti basta poco tempo per iniziare a
prendere parte all'attività sociali nel
tour o posto di lavoro maghi che cacchio
stiamo a parlare le tue emozioni ti
controllano più di quanto tu controlli
loro beh assolutamente zio ti piacciono
gli eventi sociali in cui ci si deve
mascherare o sono previste attività come
giochi di ruolo
assolutamente sì per una miriade di
motivi il primo che semi maschera la
gente non mi riconosce quindi a posto e
secondo magnificato i giochi di ruolo
se la stanza è piena stai vicino ai muri
evitando il 100
roma adesso che vuol dire comunque sì è
vero sta cosa se ci penso perché è vero
comunque ai la tendenza a procrastinare
fino a quando non c'è abbastanza tempo
per fare tutto un primo tarsia nelle
situazioni stressanti abbastanza ritieni
che sia più gratificante essere
apprezzati dagli altri piuttosto che
essere potenti no hai sempre provato
interesse per cose non convenzionali
ambigue ad esempio libri opere d'arte o
film perché non sono convenzionali e
sono ambigui libri o le opere d'arte il
film in questo caso sì però non so
perché ai premi spesso l'iniziativa
nelle situazioni sociali not signori
abbiamo finalmente finito il test
vediamo che cosa mi esce fuori ci siamo
solo all'architetto sono 79 per cento
introverso ma anche di più solo 9 81 per
cento intuitivo 53 per cento focalizzato
sulla logica il 47 per cento dei
principi ecco questa qua è una merda
nella mia vita perché molte volte vanno
in contrasto fedor o per gli architetti
rappresentano solo il 2 per cento della
popolazione a paci don grazie a trichet
che chi è che se chi è architetto
friedrich nietzsche michelle obama ilon
mask e christopher nolan madonna tutte
persone che stimo beh è difficile non
stimare queste persone effettivamente
però vladimir putin attenzione l'hanno
fatto che non cecchino in mano ma cosa
che a volte white heisenberg madonna che
è bellissimo twitter non ho visto altro
nibali non so le topping continua non
aver visto di spalle però grazie per un
lannister non ho visto neanche the
witcher ok ok gandalf il grigio grazie è
bellissimo katniss everdeen katniss
everdeen belle difatti è molto vero
perché mi cifra con sa quando guardo
hunger games i minimi di speck e
tantissimi teatri sono identico e poi
abbiamo jay gatsby nel grande gatsby
bellissimo questa la mia personale c
ditemi un po la vostra nei commenti
ditemi che cosa ne pensate
cercherò di essere veramente nel modo
più totale sincero
la risposta che non mi piacevano
purtroppo c'è purtroppo per fortuna si
fa così niente spero che mi sia piaciuto
se vi è piaciuto subito lasciato
commento mi piace anche per i social che
come tradizione senza doversi insieme mi
era come sempre ci ritroviamo ad un
flusso video era ragazzi
[Musica]